in this video you're gonna learn how to
transform parent functions specifically
parent functions that are in this form
or this form now a lot of times students
get a little bit confused because
they're not sure whether they do the
horizontal shift first or the horizontal
stretch or compress first and that's
what we're gonna clear up in this video
so when it's in this form here where you
can see the B value is factored out what
you want to do is you actually want to
take the B into consideration first
meaning that you're going to either
stretch horizontally or compress
horizontally the x coordinates of your
graph and then you're going to follow
that up by shifting it left or right and
that's what the H indicates here now the
important thing to remember is that the
number grouped with the X okay in both
cases here the B and the H are grouped
with the X they're gonna have the
opposite effect on the graph so what I
mean by that is that this H here C if
it's X minus H it's actually going to go
to the right H if it's X plus h it's
going to go to the left H it's going to
shift where is it the be if like B is
greater than one like say for example to
it would actually divide all the
x-coordinates by two if it was like a
half you would actually multiply the x
coordinates by two so it has the
opposite effect it has the reciprocal
effect this B value and then here this
coefficient a this is our vertical
stretch or compress if a is greater than
one it's a vertical stretch if it's
between zero and one it's gonna be a
vertical shrink or a vertical compress
and if it's negative it's going to
reflect over the x-axis so it's a
reflection if it's negative and then
lastly the K that's going to be our
vertical shift up and down now if it's
in this form here what you can see is
that this B value is like distributed in
that's not factored out and so when it's
in this form what you want to do is you
actually want to do the horizontal shift
first and then follow it by the
horizontal stretch or compress we're
gonna go through a number of examples
I'll show you how this works the first
example we're gonna work with is the
absolute value function and you're
familiar with this graph already it's a
v-shaped graph if you're not familiar
just go ahead and make a table pick some
negative values 0 and some positive
values and you're going to get that
you shaped graph but what I want to
compare and show you is the difference
between graphing it in this form G of x
equals the absolute value of two times X
minus 2 and G of X equals the absolute
value of the quantity 2x minus 4 now you
might be saying Mario these are exactly
the same right if I distribute the two
that's 2x minus 4 which is exactly what
we have here and you'd be exactly right
and we're going to end up with the exact
same graph but when you describe the
transformations the actual steps that
you go through are going to be different
so let me see if I can explain
so in this form you can see that that 2
is factored out ok so when it's factored
out it's in this form here which means
that we actually want to take the
horizontal stretch or compress into a
account first so what we're gonna do is
we're not actually going to multiply the
X values by 2 this has the opposite
effect we're gonna divide the x-values
by 2 so it's gonna be a horizontal
shrink so what that means now is at this
point here is going to stay exactly
where it's at but this point here see
how the x coordinate is 2 it's going to
be shrinking so that means that this
point is actually going to be at 1 now
same thing over here see how this is at
negative 2 a horizontal shrink this is
going to put this at negative 1 so what
you can see here is we've got a graph
that's been horizontally compressed then
what we're going to do is we're gonna do
this part second the H value so we're
gonna say this is going to shift not -2
not left 2 it has the opposite effect
when it's a group of the X like that
it's actually gonna shift right 2
so each of these points I'm just gonna
go right to this point over here right
to this point over here right to and so
you can see that's our final graph right
there ok now let's take a look at letter
B G of x equals the absolute value of 2x
minus 4 notice now that the 2 is not
factored out this is all you know
multiplied together here what we want to
do is in this form right here is we
actually want to do the horizontal shift
first so the minus 4 actually tells us
that this graph here is going to be
shifted right 4 so this vertex here is
now going to be at 1 2 3 4 right here
and you can see then it's going up with
a slope of 1 ok like this same thing
over here
okay so that's our shifting right for
okay now the two we want to take into
account remember this has the opposite
effect on the graph this is actually not
going to multiply the X values by two
but actually divide the x coordinates by
two so this point here instead of being
at four is now going to be at two ok
this point over here which is at zero is
zero divided by two is still zero so
that's going to stay exactly where it's
at and then take for example another
point here let's say this is 1 2 3 4 5 6
comma 2 it's a little bit of high here
this is actually going to be at 3 comma
2 which is right there so you can see
now that the graph is actually going to
look like this and if you look closely
these two graphs are exactly the same
see how we're at vertex is at 2 and it's
going up like so same thing here its
vertex is at 2 and it's going up at the
same rate okay example number two we're
going to work with the square root
function and you know what the shape of
that graph looks like it's kind of like
a parabola on its side just the top half
there so we're going to do is letter A
and letter B again look at these two
functions you might say to yourself well
Mario it looks like they're exactly the
same if I distribute this 1/3 I'm
getting 1/3 X plus 1 the same as the
example a here but the process of
graphing these the process of describing
the transformations is going to be
different for both of these so let me
see how you show you how you would work
these so for this one notice that the B
value is not factored out so that means
it's in this form here and when it's in
this form what we have to do is do our
horizontal shift first so this plus 1 is
actually going to take this graph here
and it's going to shift all the x
coordinates left 1 so instead of being
here at 0 0 we're going to be over here
at negative 1 instead of being over here
we're gonna shift to the left 1 we're
going to be right there instead of being
at 4 2 we're going to be at 3 2 so
everything just shifted left 1
okay now the 1/3 this was going to have
an effect on the horizontal stretch or
compress but remember this
actually has the reciprocal effect so it
looks like you're dividing the x-values
by three you're actually going to be
multiplying the X values by three so
this is actually a horizontal stretch so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take all the x-values and multiply them
by three so instead of being at negative
one here we're going to be at negative
three right here instead of being at
zero well 0 times three is still going
to be zero so that stays where it's at
and then this one over here instead of
being at positive three you're going to
be at positive nine so four five six
seven eight and nine and the y-value is
going to stay the same though okay so
we're just changing the the x
coordinates and you can see this is a
horizontal stretch okay now for letter B
you can see that this B value has been
factored out and so what that tells us
is that we actually have to do the
horizontal stretch or compress first
followed by the horizontal shift so what
does the one third do well again just
like we talked about over here it's
gonna have the reciprocal effect it's
actually going to multiply the X values
by three zero times three is you're
still going to be zero one times three
is going to be three so one two three
again the Y value stays the same and
over here we're at four comma two so now
we're going to be at 12 comma two so
this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 comma
2 right about there so you can see we
did the horizontal stretch first
now all the values are going to be
shifted not positive 3 but the opposite
left 3 so this points going to be 1 2 3
right here this point is going to be 1 2
3 right here and this point is going to
be at 1 2 3
right about there but what you can see
is we're getting the exact same graph
it's just that the process of getting to
that graph was a little bit different
the order of the transformations was
different okay example 3 we're gonna
work with f of x equals x squared this
is the parabola graph that you're
familiar with but what I want to show
you now is how to use a table to get the
final coordinates of you know your new
function here G of X so G of x equals 2
times 1/2 X minus 3 the quantity squared
plus 1 so the question is is what do we
do first as far as
transformations well you can see that we
don't have that B value factored out
it's actually just like this form here
so what that tells us is that we have to
do our horizontal shift first so you can
see our B value is three minus three
actually is going to take this graph is
going to shift it right three which
means that we're adding three to the x
coordinates so what I'm going to do is I
just took these parent function
coordinates here negative 2 4 negative 1
1 et cetera just with this equation here
and what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to add 3 to the x coordinates so
that's going to make this positive 1
that's going to make this positive 2
that's going to make this 3 4 5 but the
Y values are gonna stay the same because
this is just shifting to the right 3 now
what we're gonna do is were going to
focus on the horizontal stretch and
compress this is our B value remember it
has the opposite effect it looks like
you're multiplying by 1/2 you're
actually multiplying by the reciprocal 2
over 1 so this is actually going to be a
horizontal stretch which means that
we're multiplying the x-coordinates by 2
so now instead of being at 1 we're gonna
be here at 2 4 6 8 and 10
but the y-values are gonna stay the same
now we're gonna go focus on the a value
here the 2 actually has the effect on
the vertical component it's gonna
multiply the y-values by 2 it's a
vertical stretch so the x-values are
gonna stay the same 2 4 6 8 and 10 but
the Y values are going to be doubled so
this is going to be 8 2 0 2 & 8 the last
thing we want to do is this K value here
which is going to shift it up 1 so it
has the same effect if it's positive 1
up 1 if it was negative 1 to go down 1
so that means we're gonna add 1 to all
the Y value since it's shifting in the
vertical direction so this is going to
be 9 3 1 3 & 9 but the X values are
gonna stay the same 2 4 6 8 and 10 all
you have to do now is plot these points
and you're gonna have your new
transformed quadratic function okay so
it sounds like you guys are really
enjoying this video and if you like my
teaching style I have a lot more
information
regarding algebra two topics in my
algebra 2 video course so definitely
check that out if you need help with
your algebra 2 studies in your class it
goes through a typical algebra 2
curriculum and it goes into a lot of
detail similar to this video but
covering all the different topics in
algebra 2 but let's go through another
example this one were to be talking
about reflections and this is also one
that sometimes confuses students but
here we're working with f of X equals 3
to the X you can see this is an
exponential growth function but now
we're going to look at two different
versions we've got this one version a
where we have 3 to the negative x plus 1
here we have version B 3 to the negative
quantity X minus 1 so again the question
is is what do we do first what do we do
second what do we do third etc well when
you look at it in this form you can see
that as opposed to this form you can see
that the negative is factored out ok so
when it's factored out that's this form
here this one is not factored out it's
this form here so what we have to do for
the letter A is we actually have to do
the shift first so you can see this plus
1 is actually going to shift this graph
left 1 so all these key points here I'm
just going to shift left 1 so we're
gonna go here this one's going to be
over here and this one here is going to
be right on the y axis so that's going
to be step number 1 shifting left 1 now
the negative acts what it does is it
makes all the X values the opposite
which reflects it over the y axis so
what you can see now is that this point
here is going to reflect it's going to
be over here at positive 1 this point
stead of being here at negative 2 it's
gonna be a positive 2 and this point
here is right on the y axis is gonna
stay there ok so that's going to be our
final graph right here ok now for letter
B what we're gonna do because the
negative 1 is factored out that's this
first form here we're actually going to
reflect over the y-axis first so this
point instead of being at 1/3 it's going
to be here at negative 1/3 this one's
right on the y axis so it's going to
stay where it's at and then this point
here is going to be right there so all I
did is reflect over the y-axis but now
what we're going to do is we're going to
follow that up by shifting
not minus one but right one so each of
these points is going to shift right one
this is point is going to be right here
this point is going to be right here and
this point is going to be right there so
you can see we're ending up with the
exact same graph it's just a matter of
how do we get to that you know what
steps do we do first second third so if
you've been following my channel for a
while now you know that Mario's math
degree is all about making learning math
less stressful for you so that you can
raise your grade pass your class and go
on and pursue your dreams if you want to
learn more about transforming parent
functions check out the other video I
did right there and I'll see you over in
that video